given a a voicemail given a text message
it can almost immediately recognize
there's a problem right and then it's
getting it fed back into the network to
find the source and stop so you know as
long as you have good statistical
samples of these behaviors once you see
one you don't need to see a million of
them you need see one you see one call
now you know it's a deep fake you see
one voicemail you can actually take
action so I think it's getting a sense
of urgency among everybody here to take
action
Alex guichi Welcome to our show and for
this fun conversation I'm excited to
engage with you on your background and
your history and and the youil and what
you're doing today and talking
everything about communication I mean
you've been in this space for more than
two decades you're obviously highly
technical you're with a PhD in computer
science and AI but also your background
as vice president Within AOL and and
having spent I guess what is it 17 years
now at at umil and so so you you
probably are one of the most
knowledgeable people in the world on
email phone calls communication and and
the security around it because that's
obviously what you do so so I'm really
excited to just learn from you over
these 20 minutes and and and try to get
as much information that I that I can
and learn from so again Alex thank you
for being thank you for having me and
hopefully I can live up to all that I'm
I'm a very determined that that that you
will so Alex take take me back for a
second to as you got started in in voice
over I and AOL and communication what
does this mean to you how did you get
here uh so I got here by accident I got
here because I was sitting in a store
before uh mobile devices were really
common and I didn't want to overpay for
a mountain bike and I thought I wish
there was a number I could go just call
and say specialize whatever the bike was
how much is it on Amazon and so we
decided to build that and we and we we
built what turned out to be one of the
first voice portals where you could say
where's in the aest Chinese restaurant
Etc we did that 25 years ago uh that
required no one about telephony to do it
at the time we created a 1 1800 number
you could call had cages of servers to
answer calls and just been one thing and
another since then fortunately AOL like
we did we they built it we became a
voice mechanism for getting the AOL
email back in the day before before even
blackberries were getting really popular
and I'm just stuck at stuck out this
area since then wait what happened back
there so you you created a service in
which people were able to call a800
number ask a question that that and and
how would it work how did how did how
did it actually run so back then we
actually had servers that were answering
the phone call that had dialogic cards
on them so it's Hardware cards that
could answer the phone calls the phone
calls were routed over the public switch
telephone Network to those servers in
the same they way they would have been
routed to say a voicemail box at a at a
carrier and we just built some really
smart code that manag the servers found
information on the internet buil
parameters and tried to answer questions
and so it was sort of like a vision for
Siri with Siri and we only got started
on wait and and it it spoke it it spoke
back spoke back using text to speech
again using Hardware cards to generated
it was it almost feels insane but it was
a predecessor of Siri in a lot of ways
and when it was part of AOL it had a
million people paying five bucks a month
to use it after a couple years when AOL
bought it and scaled it up so we built a
real business on what was essentially a
voice way to get to your email a voice
way to get to your voicemail your voice
way to get to a few other pieces of
information like restaurants and I think
movies were in there I can't remember
anymore wow and then you led this within
AOL afterwards that that's what you were
doing as ex part of the team that was
trying to scale this out through AOL and
do other products we did a a phone
number product at AOL is part of aim for
those of you could remember aim is you
know kit as a messaging service and you
know after a while I was there for a
while it was really fun working with
that sort of audience and decided to go
do something else after that all right
so so after that where did you end up
going to so I ended up going to this
company called Emil which was really
fledgling then it was a couple guys who
built a little voicemail service they
had a couple of cool features one was it
could play it out a service message to a
caller uh based on the phone number so
you meet someone in a bar you decide you
want to keep talking to them hit a
button now it's going to play out of
service when they call and it had
another little feature that was a
personalized greeting so each person who
called you could get their own greeting
so Mom gets a greeting your friends get
a greeting Etc that's that's how email
started I ended up as a investor and a
board member and then kind of found
myself running it after a while and our
goal was hey let's replace voicemail
that the carriers have with something we
could build that's way more interesting
than what even these two guys had sort
of created it we tried carriers don't
move quickly money does move quickly and
we ran out of money and said okay we
better go do something else but turned
out we had a million people using our
Blackberry app which we just built as a
proof of concept from there we decided
to grow it in the voeville space and
eventually realized nobody cared about
Bo what they cared about was playing out
of service messages to phone numbers
they don't like it used to be the failed
hookup the you know person you got to
know didn't want to know anymore it
moved do robocallers it moved to people
all of the email users blocking the same
1800 number the same 312 number and so
then about 2015 we grow the base pretty
M pretty pretty well but we said this is
no future here but the future isn't
protecting people and with that's how we
got into what we do today we wanted to
block calls we wanted to figure out what
voicemails they were getting and how to
label them so you knew if it was a Spam
or scam and generally allow people to
communicate more safe incredible can you
share with me a little bit about
the the evolution of spam social
engineering fishing and in real-time
communication so I I know I grew up
knowing that my grandmother was getting
phone calls to buy cruises and and it
was and and so you know I remember
hearing you know constantly warning you
know elderly and and people that are
perhaps less equipped to go and and and
make and and check these things for
themselves you know that you know
whether it's a good decision is is this
really where where it started or what
was the space how did I think it started
with people trying to do scams that they
would have done in person to someone or
through the mail through the phone right
so there were lots and lots of different
scams a cruise ship one there's you've
won a big prize all you got to do is uh
you know go somewhere and wire money to
someone I it's been very consistent uh
what's changed is the level of
automation so the fact that you can do a
huge volume of calls uh or text messages
these days at very low cost and did an
enormous number of targets that's that's
relatively new that's an evolution uh I
think how they work and the targeting
the data sources that are there from
breaches for example or just even public
data BRS it's easy to buy a list of
phone numbers of Alzheimer patients over
80 if you want a Target list there's a
Target list and so you just call those
people have to call everybody with your
Scamp so you see more calls targeted
calls and now you're starting to see AI
as part of this whole thing so AI
cloning voices so oh Joe Biden's telling
me I when the plers flaring out it must
be real so I mean that's a silly example
but we're seeing lots of really
interesting use of AI for bot so even if
you answer you're not talking to a
person you're talking to a bot and the
bot's qualifying you getting you started
and then transferring you to a person
and so it's just automation intelligence
aiding the scammers all the way through
right I heard a somebody from a cyber
security Venture Capital fund to
mentioned the other day the term spray
and prey right that you're that now that
their ability to now execute these spam
calls or social engineering or fishing
efforts at large volumes due to due to
the emergence of AI but and and you're
talking about Robo calls and the ability
to automate the calling and we've had
text to speech which now obviously
sounds more and more like like human
what how how do I guess deep fix fiden
this from your perspective so um I guess
deep fakes obviously are the the the
cloning of somebody's identity so it's
not a random voice that you hear but
it's actually a voice that you trust so
the really interesting thing is that
people are at risk of being deep faked
because they use voicemail so if you
have a greeting hey you've reached
Michael I'm really busy I'd rather you
text me you know but go ahead and leave
a message that's enough as you know to
do a decent quality voice qu so people
just set up their voice now they've got
the possibility of voice clone with live
voice F you've got the possibility of an
AI generated interaction that's being
transcribed until you answer then you
press one and now it goes to a person so
Ai and deep fakes is affecting the the
newer products that people are using
right the the VOA people are used to
using the greetings the live voicea it's
all extremely dangerous because of the
deep things and we're signed to see them
is this something that you think is
already happening or is this something
that were still geing up for for the
future because there's a lot of people
who say it's definitively happen
happening already so there was a deep
fake of Joe Biden in New Hampshire where
the call went out to a bunch of
democratic voters saying don't bother
going to the polls now you know Sav your
vote for the the the um the general
election don't vote the New Hampshire
primer it was Joe Biden's voice Robo
called to a bunch of people um who then
it had an impact right on the number of
people who went to the polls so that's
already happened there's other there's a
Cong rman in Pennsylvania whose
constituents are saying there's a deake
of him asking them to donate money to a
fake police charity so deep takes are
already out there at um with you know
with celebrity or known people um we're
starting to see we've seen for a while
but AI generated voice messages saying
you Dad I'm in trouble those kind of
things the grandparents scam uh not have
full interaction with the a family
member but enough to get them to call or
text a number it's happening and it's
just going to scale like we're kind of
unfortunately right before this big wave
of the stuff that's going to happen and
our prediction is by this election we're
going to see all sorts of stuff both
sides everywhere local National doesn't
matter yeah absolutely and and so far
we're talking about consumers and the I
guess real-time communication channels
of of consumers is this is this also a
problem for organizations or Enterprises
or do they have already existing defense
mechanisms that cover that and really
the problem is the well I think we know
that the organizations aren't defending
against smishing and fishing
successfully as it is and adding a layer
of intelligence will just make it harder
for them so as the scamers sound like
the CEO and we all know we've seen demos
of it we know some of those are out
there if you get a call that sounds like
your CEO saying hey I really need you to
go buy 10,000 of gift cards for this
event get it sent here who's G to
question it right and so it's going to
be I think Enterprises are way more
vulnerable to this stuff than they
I I I I 100% agree with you and so so
let's talk about you know you mail and
and how you see the space evolving
because what you know you're when we're
looking at if we're putting as a mission
statement let's create a a situation in
which people are secure from spam
fishing fishing um Etc what does it
actually entail what do we need to do
because you're saying it's it's
happening now so what's the so the way
we look at it is you know we have a nice
app that helps protect people when the
calls and texts finally get through the
Network and land on somebody but that's
too late what we need to do is stop it
right at the start which is go after
where the calls and texts and these
fishing and fishing scams originate and
so we've already started moving in the
direction of helping carriers understand
here's illegal unlawful fraudulent
traffic that you're putting on the
network you your customer is making
these calls and we use our Emil uh
audience as a sensor Network to detect
that stuff and have commercial products
for carriers where we can show them
here's all your illegal events so they
can take action same with imposters if
there's an imposter pretending to be a
bank it's too late to try to stop them
at an account takeover that resulted
from that the smiing or fishing attempt
you really want to figure out where
those are coming from and shut them off
and make it so hard to get any track so
that people go into some other business
and we're putting a lot of our energy
there we love the consumers they're
great they give us data but the future
is being able to notice what's happening
quickly enough to stop it from taking
King off M and what is the response from
the carrier side so the large Telos that
are now all of a sudden finding
themselves in the middle of all this how
how are they reacting I think there's
different kinds of Telos right so the
the T-Mobil the AT&T's Verizon they're
trying to stop illegal traffic from
hitting their users right they want to
block you see spam likely you see them
making attempts the more interesting
part is the wholesale part of the
network that tends to be the part of the
network where the calls come on and they
sell to business businesses and the bad
guys are just another kind of business
that's where I think that they're still
trying to get their arms around this
problem and what does it mean right a
lot of the carers think they're really
clean but they actually have a decent
amount of illegal traffic even though
they're trying not to there are other
carers out there that we see the FCC and
others shutting down that pretty clearly
didn't have a lot of legal traffic they
existed solely to Def fraad so I think
we're seeing though that there's a big
movement now to try to stop the problems
at the source and have the security
guard where the calls are being made not
where they're ending right I mean and I
can only imagine you know how big of a
of a task it is to take a situation I
can I can't I don't even know how many
phone calls there are maybe you do in in
the US let's say for a day and the
ability to without friction with
relatively low cost to be able to
identify the illegal behavior and then
stop it with with low false positive
rate because you don't want to create
friction right highly competitive with
each other and we know that you know
people don't like when when there's
friction in their in their experience so
and and all of that has to happen very
quickly because as you're saying it's
happening now so it's not like we're
planning for five years in advance we're
we're planning for end of 2024 so you're
absolutely right and I think the key is
there's technology now I I've seen Lots
we all are working on different aspects
of it but given a call given a voicemail
given a text message it can almost
immediately re recognize there's a
problem right and then it's getting it
fed back into the network to find the
source and stop it so you know as long
as you have good statistical samples of
these behaviors once you see one you
don't need to see a million of them you
need to see one you see one call now you
know it's a deep fake you see one call
one voicemail you can actually take
action so I think it's getting a sense
of urgency among everybody here to take
action and so I think that's a a
challenge like if you've been a carrier
whole job has been to make the call go
from point A to point B now you're being
told hey you need to stop a lot of these
calls or some of your customers are bad
that's a really huge change in mindset
and operations and it can impact Revenue
right it can impact your business a
negative way may even know so it's going
to be a challenge but I think it's where
a lot of the stuff is going to have to
the battle's gonna have to be fought and
are you optimistic that there's the
right people in place to give it give
the effort and and the understanding
that that it has that we need to create
these Solutions and and even if it has
some impact on the short-term Revenue
this is something that has to happen
what what's your stance on sort of the
optimism around how equipped we are to
deal with this I I think the technology
is there and it's the will and the
ability to roll it out that's going to
be the challenge I think businesses are
getting educated I think this is one
place where the government is playing a
really interesting role where the FCC is
basically telling carriers you can't
just look the other way and say I didn't
know it was bad you've got to you're
going to be part responsible so I think
as the notion of we're partially
responsible permeates the space you'll
see more action so I'm pretty optimistic
I don't see it as a solved problem
though or a super solvable problem in
the short run it just gets better and
better over over time make make the bad
guys work harder and there'll be less of
the less of the scams and damage but you
know it's in the billions or tens of
billions of dollars a year in terms of
fishing fishing smishing damage
depending on who you talk to tens of
billions of dollars a year a big number
it's a big number and so we can just
keep reducing it 10% a year for some
period of time that's that's my
optimistic take and I think it's not
just the the dollar amount but it's also
the impact associated with the dollar
amount because as you're you know what
what is what is what is$ 10 billion doar
a year of losses in fishing represents
it represents potentially millions or or
hundreds of thousands of people that
were that now lost trust in the system
and you have the the remaining billions
of people who are exposed to the to this
content to this experience through the
news and through social media which are
now saying wait can I trust what I'm
hearing can I trust what I'm saying and
so there's a it sounds like just the SEC
even the second order effects of this
are quite dis it is and I think you make
a great point it's not only it's not
only financial it's actually there there
there's been somebody who was killed
recently over a scam right in Ohio an
elderly man got a prison scam and the
Uber driver is coming to take money from
him to go give to the scammer who had no
idea he shot her right thought she was
part of the scam and killed her I mean
that's the worst possible outcome of a
scam it's not just he lost money but
somebody died and so these things are
actually really dangerous right it's
like you know why you tell your kids
never get in the car with strangers now
it's all like don't talk to strangers
right stranger danger is a phone call
it's a text message I mean it's it's
insane but adults now worry about
stranger D it's it's what you told
you're three-year-old or you're
six-year-old you know you're not telling
your your 40y olds and your 80-year-old
Mom right it's absolutely absolutely
completely agree Alex what's what's ni
for you mail what are you excited about
I'm excited to roll out what we've been
rolling out so we've rolled out to over
20 carriers that are using our product
there's 3,000 in the us alone who could
I think that's a great Market we have
five Enterprises we now protecting their
brand there's clearly hundreds of those
we could do so ours is just let's go
attack this Market we can do a great job
and get our product out there and see
how much of a difference we can make
we're in it for for making a difference
and 3,000 car 3,000 carriers he said
3,000 wholesale carriers in the US we
know that because there's a database you
after file if you're a carrier called $
499 filing with the FCC over 3,000
entries maybe even closer to four some
AR real some are a little a guy at his
basement you know with one server but
3,000 carriers who are in business as
being a carrier from you know at least
some customers some some Revenue some
calls it's a lot these are and are these
all operating under telecommunication
technology or are some of them operating
under under you know just the in the the
the cellular service and the internet
what's is there a distinction there no a
lot it's not really a distinction a lot
of them are internet based right so they
there'll be a a carrier that specializes
in wholesale service for hospitals so
they'll provide the phone service for
the hospital and get them good rates
there's cares at in taking traffic from
point A to point B cheaply carries
specialize in being gateways from
traffic coming from different countries
overseas there's all sorts of of
carriers here and some just try to be
lowcost providers in a diff in a
particular region or to a particular
industry so you know there's probably
300 400 500 carries that really matter
out of that big batch but we're at 20
that gives us some some room to run and
we want to run and help because the more
we get at these carries using our stuff
the fewer these calls are going to be on
it absolutely Alex I want to wish you
best of luck with the email I want to
thank you for this amazing conversation
I I learned a ton as I always so so I
really appreciate it and I'm wishing you
best of luck and then as as much as I'm
inspired by the your your um
professionalism and your your knowledge
in the space I'm I'm just as inspired by
your commitment to what you're doing for
the last more than two decades and so uh
I think it it speaks volumes to your
excitement in this space your commitment
commit to to making a large impact here
and it it pretty much sounds like you
you started a space and now you're
helping secure it and so it's it's
really great well thank you very much
there's a lot of fun and you ask great
questions thank you Alex thank you